- Welcome back y'all to Premiere
Week from New York City.
Lin-Manuel Miranda's Here.
(audience cheering)
- Today marks the start
of Hispanic Heritage Month
and we have two more Latin
stars joining us to celebrate.
He is one of the biggest
Hispanic musicians today.
Four of his albums have topped
the billboard Latin albums chart.
He's also worked with artists
like Christina Aguilera,
Black Pink, and Cardi B.
His new album will be out this fall
and she, I love her, known as The Voice
Of New York on Power 105.1.
You can find her podcast, Angie Martinez
In Real Life on YouTube and
wherever you get your podcast
give it up for Angie Martinez and Ozuna.
(upbeat funk music)
- [Ozuna] Oh!
- I was like, you know.
- [Angie] I'm trying to hide.
- Are you trying to get away from me?
But today marks the start
of Hispanic Heritage Month.
So what does this month mean to y'all?
- Means we get to celebrate.
- Yeah
- It means we get to show respect and, and
and honor people and, and
talk about our history
and our culture and
maybe have some good food
from what I hear today,
especially when I do that later.
And you know, it's just a, it's
it's a moment to like,
look at where we're from,
look at what we're proud of.
- I think the same.
- Yeah, you too?
- I think the same. Family time.
You need like time for you,
like Hispanic is everything.
I think it's everything.
Good food, good mom.
And celebrate every day.
- Everyday is our day.
- Yeah, for sure
- Oh, I love you.
- Yeah, that sounds fun.
That sounds awesome.
- It's type of party? Your type of party.
- I was like, well,
that just sounded great.
So did you spend a lot of time
at your grandparents place in Puerto Rico?
- Yeah. Puerto Rico.
- So Lin, did you spend time
at your grandparents' place
in Puerto Rico as well?
- Yes. I, I would spend every
summer in La Gata, Puerto Rico
and it was, you know,
it's, it's interesting.
Like it wasn't, I, it was
not the tourist version.
Oh, well, there I am on the beach.
- [Angie] Aww, look at you.
- You can count my ribs.
(speaking in foreign language)
That's but yeah, it was not
like a touristy experience.
My grandparents worked, my
grandmother ran a travel agency.
My grandfather worked at a bank
and I just ran around town.
I just ran around Pueblo
and, and made movies
with my grandfather's, like,
literally my grandfather
would borrow the cam quarter
from the surveillance for
the bank that he worked at.
And there's me making a movie
where I'm, I had no friends
and they're literally just doing
an imaginary fight with no one.
- You seem so cool.
I don't know why you didn't have friends.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah. It's, I dunno
why no one wanted to be
in this movie with me, where
I'm hitting myself with a mop.
- Or maybe you were just afraid
from childhood to ask any family to join.
- Yeah, exactly.
- They start yelling.
- So that's like stationary
camera and I just
it was like a, you know,
I just spent my time in
I had an amazing time at Puerto Rico.
Amazing summers there.
- [Angie] Ah, I love that.
- Beautiful. and Angie,
you're third generation.
- I wish I had that
- Puerto Rican, Cuban.
I know, but you, you,
I love your mix of your
Puerto Rican, Cuban, and Dominican, so.
- [Angie] Yeah.
How, how did that shape your identity?
- A good mix right? That's a good mix.
- Yeah, hard mix.
- That's good eating.
- It turned out really well.
- Thank you.
And now I'm from New York also.
That's why I have in the New Yorican also.
But I go to Puerto Rico, like,
so I have a different experience than you.
I don't go there like, oh, this
is where I grew up in this.
I go there, like this connection
and this yearning and this,
like, I feel like I'm happy.
So happy to be home.
It's like, it's just a
little, little touristy.
I am a little touristy.
Cause I am from New York.
So unfortunately, but,
but I love Puerto Rico.
- That's what I, that's what I live there
because I'm just connecting,
like for everything I'm work
like around the world, but
I'm coming back to Puerto Rico
and say, oh, actually like that.
- [Kelly] It's your roots.
- [Angie] Yeah.
- It's awesome.
- It really is a beautiful
island, it really is.
- Yeah
- There's so much pride.
There's so much pride.
There's so much, just people take pride
in not just being Puerto
Rican, but of the island
and how they take care of it.
And even, you know, we
did a lot of work when
when the hurricanes came and
it was a real understanding
of like, especially in
the crew that I was with
and was working with, it's
like, we're here to help
but this is not like a charity thing.
Like everybody was helping together.
Everybody had pride, like we're
struggling, but we're in it.
We're getting it in, there was, it just,
I don't know, I love seeing that.
I love people seeing building
up their own communities
and creating like makeshift
schools and makeshift.
You remember when Maria first
just happened and people were
- [Lin-Manuel] It was hands
on deck, hands on deck
- Hands on, all hands on deck.
And there was pride,
so much pride in that.
And it was really an amazing
experience for me to be
on the island and have
that experience with
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- people that were born and raised there.
And it just made me feel
proud to have any, you know
to have that type of connection there.
- Yeah. How do you think it shaped you
like musically speaking?
- Like.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Kelly] I get a little
bit. I get a little bit,
for everything, I got a
little bit just a little bit.
- You understand the idea.
(speaking foreign language)
- Got everything. Got
everything, all of it.
(speaking foreign language)
- That's what I was gonna say.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- He made me to it. He beat me to it.
- People see the legend on the island.
- [Kelly] I, of course, yeah.
My, dad dance with me
go see like, 90, 92, 91,
Like the start with dragon town.
So the culture is everything
in Puerto Rico for the music urban
and the arts to learn my
know, like everything.
Everything is art in Puerto Rico.
Every family got a little bit like artists
a little bit like sport
guys. It's everything.
- Music is everywhere
- Music is everything.
You only you got 3 million
people in Puerto Rico.
That's incredible.
(audience applauding)
- [Angie] In the world.
- So wait, so tell us,
tell us about your new song
that just dropped just yesterday right?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] What, what is it
called? What is it? What is it?
- La Copa.
- [Kelly] Okay, La Copa.
- La Copa is, is one, a new song.
I have like a different
like, like beats is something
like a rock, like a like old music.
It's it's so it's so different.
Like it's classic music,
It's all different.
Like it's a, a band music.
I have a different, like I regular,
I don't know how to say in English
- [Lin-Manuel] Arrangement, yeah
- Yeah, it, it have
like different thing in,
in the, in the song,
so that's my new song.
La Copa.
I'm recording video in Spain.
So it's crazy.
- Wow, in Spain.
- [Kelly] That's so cool, I love Spain.
- Yeah I love it too.
- So Lin, we're coming up on
the, the fifth anniversary
of hurricane Maria, which
devastated Puerto Rico.
Tell us about your family's work
with the Hispanic Federation.
- Yeah. You know, I think
that what I realized our
lane was gonna be as a family
was to really support artists
and artistic organizations on the island.
So, you know, that started
with taking Hamilton there
and raised 15 million
for artists and arts.
- Wow.
(audience applauding)
- And we continued that work.
And so we've, we've done that.
We, we partnered with Google Arts.
There's amazing artwork in
the museums in Puerto Rico.
And Google Arts has partnered
with us to digitize all of that.
So people all over the world
can see the amazing art
coming out of Puerto Rico.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and, and
continuing to just sort of
support artists that fund
and, and, and since Maria and
and make sure that that
they're not forgotten in,
in the recovery efforts.
- Absolutely. Well, to all of you
like what can we all still do?
There's still help needed there.
So what, what is something
everybody could do?
- I think that island is gonna, you knows
been rebuilding is a, it's a long haul.
Supporting, go there go to
Puerto Rico, spend money there.
- Invest, yeah, yeah, yeah, invest.
Let's go
- Everybody likes to
just go after the show.
We're gonna, we're gonna go.
- Look under your chairs.
(audience applauding)
- So one thing central
to every culture is food.
These guys have brought
if each brought actually one
of their favorite dishes.
So Lin, we're gonna start with you.
So what did you bring?
- Well, I brought it three months early.
This is an early Christmas present.
- This is three month's old?
- No, no, no, but Coquito
is a Christmas drink.
- [Ozuna] Yes, that's right.
- This is rum and coconut cream.
- Do I have to wait?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- No, you don't have to wait.
Salud!
(audience applauding)
- Salud!
- Merry Christmas.
- This is in September.
- Oh, it's like an eggnog
drink. Kind of oh, but ooh.
- [Lin-Manuel] But Ooh.
- Oh
- But, drink it too fast
and you'll be taking a nap
you didn't expect to take.
So Ozuna, tell us about yours.
What's yours?
- I have tostones with
mayo-ketchup because you need,
you need mayo-ketchup for the tostones
everybody in Puerto Rico,
like, love eat tostones
with mayo-ketchup.
- And mayo-ketchup is what it sounds like.
- Mayo, mayo, ketchup.
- And ketchup.
- Ketchup.
- [Ozuna] Mayo-ketchup.
- Okay.
- So when you go to like
a Puerto Rican restaurant
and they're like, oh, this
is our special secret sauce.
- [Lin-Manuel] It's
mayonnaise and ketchup.
- [Kelly] It's not
secret, It's not secret.
- I love this. Okay.
Wait, I'm trying this.
- Let's try it, let's try it.
- Okay, Okay.
- And these are the.
- Don't tell me the calories, Angie.
- Okay.
- Ooh. There's like a
little spice maybe, or.
- You could put that sauce
on anything by the way.
- It's got a little tang to it.
- Yeah.
They know I like spice.
Yep. That was really good. I know, yep.
I, you know what I
should wash it down with?
(audience laughing and cheering)
- Okay Angie, what did you bring?
Is this an empanada?
- Yeah, I think these from
my friend's restaurant.
Right? These are from Jimmy.
So Jimmy, you know Jimmy.
- Yeah
- Jimmy's has a legendary
Jimmy's Bronx Cafe.
(audience laughing)
Wait, what I say? What I do?
Oh you know, yeah you
guys know Jimmy, right?.
- There are billion Jimmy's in the world.
- No, stop it, no there's
not. There's only one Jimmy's.
- Not in the Bronx.
- Thank you, there's only
one, Jimmy's Bronx Cafe
is like legendary.
- Yeah that's legendary
- I thought it was just like guy
and I'm like just the
one. You know, Bob, right?
Like, awesome.
- You guys know Jimmy's stop it.
(audience applause)
Anyway, he has have another
restaurant now in the Bronx.
Con Sofrito. Have you
been it's really good.
- [Lin-Manuel] It's great.
- Anyway, so these are from there.
These are, and I told you
I got a little Cuban in me
so I grew up eating empanadas.
My grandmother made
them every holiday, huh?
- Right? I Love my job.
Like I love it so much.
I'm just gonna try to make sure
- This is my favorite part
of every episode of the show.
- [Kelly] My God.
- [Angie] This is delicious.
- [Kelly] So good.
- Fun for us, not as much
fun for you, sorry guys.
Sorry about that.
- I wanna give a shout out, a
quick shout out to our friends
at the Puerto Rican
restaurant, Con Sofrito?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Cons Frito.
- Very good!
- Well, I try.
In the Bronx, they hooked
us up all of, of us up
with yummy food, this is so delicious.
Thank you so much for doing so.
Lin, you're providing opportunity
to future Hispanic artists
with the Miranda family fellowship.
So I want you, before you
leave to tell us about that.
- Yeah, sure.
So one of the things that, you know, you
you realize when you
have something that has
the success Hamilton had is, okay
how do I widen the doors
so that more artists
more artists of color can
have these opportunities.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And so we've sort of very organically
by providing a scholarship at this school
and providing fellowship
opportunity, developed this group
of folks called the Miranda Family Fellows
and they're artists of color.
And they have been making amazing stuff.
And we, you know, we help out with school.
We help out with internship opportunities.
We help them with paid internships
that they can have the same
opportunities other folks have.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience applauding)
- They're all just
incredible young talent.
So it's been wonderful
to support their work.
- That's really cool, man.
Opening the doors for other people.
- You're the best. You're the best.
- [Kelly] I know you're
really like so genuinely cool.
- You're like so good.
- Angie, your podcast is called
Angie Martinez In Real Life.
So how does it differ
from your radio show?
What's different about it?
- The radio show's great.
It's every day it's about
you know, it's music
it's projects that people
have and supporting
it's very like pop culture
and, and trending topics.
My podcast, it really gets
into like, just those real life
moments where you need almost
like you need somebody to talk
to type of situations.
- Yeah absolutely.
- [Angie] So those are the
conversations that we're having
- I like that it goes deeper.
- Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
- [Kelly] That's important.
- You should come on.
- Yeah. I well fine.
- [Angie] I would love that.
- Now we're friends, so
you have to invite me.
- You and I are friends,
you know my friend, Kelly.
She's gonna be on my podcast.
- But I will still call you out.
That's the kind of friend I am.